being at the white house really is an
exercise in entrepreneurship
the whole almost not in the entire but
almost the entire structure
gets revamped every four to eight years
and so you're really starting from a
very small scrappy team that has a lot
of responsibility
that has to figure out and build the
plane as you're flying it
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
nothing is more important than safety
meet quinn fitzgerald co-founder of
flare
quinn is an entrepreneur advocate and
co-founder of flair
founded in 2016 the company was created
from a passion for innovation
breaking down stereotypes and her
personal experience with assault
she attended the college of the holy
cross where her passions led her to be
the first person to design her own major
in conflict resolution
quinn later attended harvard business
school where she met her co-founder
sarah dickos desaraga
she previously served as the assistant
director of the white house business
council
during the obama administration she
currently resides in boston
gwen fitzgerald welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you today all the way
from boston right
yeah i'm so excited to be here thank you
for having me
i get to meet people from all from from
everywhere this is awesome i'm sitting
in tel aviv and today i already talked
to people in
in bolivia in boston new york and in tel
aviv
but on zoom quinn it's so such an honor
having you here because
we're going to talk about some pretty
meaningful things that you will end up
talking about safety and what you're
doing with flair but but the journey of
getting there
is is just as important if not more
important if with harvard business
school in between
and being on the white house business
council in between uh
so you know take me back and
how what is it like you know being in
the white house business council what
does that even entail
and why do you why do you go there
so a lot of people go to the white house
because they believe in making a
difference
in not just making a difference for
themselves
but making a difference for other people
and that was definitely the case
during the obama administration it was
a really cool environment to be and
surrounded by frankly a lot of young
people because more workhorses and so
as you can imagine a job at the white
house is very demanding so
a lot of other young people who are just
fully invested
every job that i've ever had in my life
has not just been a job it's really been
a part of my identity
and the way that i see the world and
trying to progress
and make the world a better place for a
lot of people so
i was on the white house business
council which is basically like a
proverbial front door to the white house
making connections between the private
sector and the
administration it's a team of only four
people
and our purview is the entire private
sector so as you can imagine
it's a lot of really interesting topics
that you get to learn about
and participate in and
near the end of my time there
what we started to learn was that
you go to the white house because you
want to create change and you get there
and you have jurisdiction
and say over a lot of how the government
participates but not everything is
entirely up to you there's a lot of laws
that make it so that you have to get
things approved or
make your purview constrained and so
what we realized is to have the biggest
impact that we could
we needed to work with people that had
their own purview
the private sector and so a lot of the
markings of success for any of the
policies that the president was doing
was to get the private sector involved
in those policies
have them make pledges have them also do
it in tandem
so that we could have the most impact
that we could so a lot of what we did
was setting up public-private
partnerships
and getting people to understand why the
president was making the policies that
he was making
but then also understanding what the
private sector needs were
and bringing that back to the government
okay can you give me a tangible example
of of a policy or a topic that
you know starts from the government and
and now because what i'm hearing is you
know this is
you know as if like the united states is
one big organization and now you have
you know the ceo makes a decision now
you have to actually go and
you know get champions across the across
the real workforce
to buy into that and and then support it
in front of others who might not
necessarily even support it
so so what are some of the things that
you were working on that made use of
this
now partnership between the public and
the private sector
i mean frankly the the list is endless
so i
i'm going to give you two different
examples because it shows the
the diversity that exists in the kind of
work
that the private sector and the
government is doing together
so one is you remember the ebola crisis
so when the ebola crisis happened um we
did a lot of work with companies
that have like medical
skills that could have an impact on the
ebola crisis
another example is there's a lot of
policies around working families and
women in the workplace
and the government can set up
laws that relate to government employees
and they can try to with the help of
congress
change laws that affect people like for
example minimum wage
and paid time off but at the same time
those things take some time so at the
same time you can get the private sector
to pledge
to give a certain amount of pay time off
for new moms and new dads right
and to help kind of make people realize
that it's not just
new moms who need time off it's also new
dads and that that should be equitable
because both parents and to be frank it
could be two moms and two dads
have that responsibility and so
tangibly really you were just on
boarding your first customers
really right i mean you're taking a
product saying let's get our first
people to buy
into this we'll sh and we'll get we'll
have case studies and we'll be able to
then
you know have that that you know
butterfly effect that snowball effect
on on the population and so you go to
harvard business school and
i don't even have to ask to know that it
was a life-changing experience
and one that hopefully one day i'll have
the privilege of experiencing
it but but really what i'm what i'm
curious to transition to is
is this idea of safety you converge on
on a company called
flare that you co-founded and and you're
dealing with with the notion of safety
and in pretty unique way so
tell me a little bit about what led you
to start flare and what is flair
yeah i definitely want to get into that
but before i do
something that you said really sparked
something that i believe in and that
transition from the government to a
startup
is something that you wouldn't think is
a normal transition
but i actually see a lot of people doing
it
a lot of my colleagues from the white
house now are going to start their own
thing
and i i think that it's fundamentally
because i believe that
being an entrepreneur is not a job it's
an approach to how you tackle life
and problems and i never
when i was working in the government
thought that i was an entrepreneur
i thought like oh that's so cool but
that could never be me and then i went
to business school which felt like a
huge transition in its own and i got
there and
making that jump to entrepreneur felt
even bigger and so i didn't call myself
an entrepreneur until i
found something that really spoke to me
here right in my heart and then i
couldn't let go of
and that passion that i had for the
solving this problem because it relates
to my own personal experience
is what drove me to start my own thing
for an idea that i could never put down
literally i was in the desert in namibia
thinking about it
and i was like that's a sign and
it was finding that thing that i then
started acting on
and then started calling myself an
entrepreneur and i remember i had this
epiphany like
a couple months in and i was like wait a
second
this isn't a job like i have been an
entrepreneur i was a little kid
who started my own lemonade stand so
that i could make money by myself
um my dad describes this one story of
like
obviously i love food so like one story
of this time where i
like constructed this like tower that i
could climb up to in the kitchen
to get the food that i wanted from the
top cabinet and he came in and he was
like oh my god you could have
you could have fallen and i realized
that being at the white house really is
an exercise in entrepreneurship the
whole
almost not in the entire but almost the
entire structure
gets revamped every four to eight years
and so you're really starting from a
very small scrappy team that has a lot
of responsibility
that has to figure out and build the
plane as you're flying it
and so it made me realize that a lot of
the skills that i needed for
entrepreneurship and for starting flair
were the same things that i had
practiced and it wasn't just
okay this is my job and i'm going to
create this thing now it was more of a
mindset
of seeing a problem recognizing that
it's a problem saying hey that can be
done better
but not stopping at that idea saying hey
i i could do that better i could make
that better you can make that better how
do we do that how do we come together
and actually
solve this that's what i think
entrepreneurship is
and so i fundamentally believe
that entrepreneurship is not a
profession it's a way of life and that
anybody can do it whether or not you're
in a big company a small company a
non-profit you have your own boutique
for example
all of that is this approach that you
take
so that's my rant that i went off of
that you inspired
uh in your transition from the
government to
flair i i love it and
uh i know i just love it that that is
the essence of entrepreneurship it's not
you know it's not a job it's not a it's
not a title it's it's a mindset it's a
feeling inside that
you know we and being a change maker and
tackling every single problem with the
entrepreneurial mindset it's not just
tackling your startups problem in one
mindset and then the rest of life in a
different way
it's constantly everything that we get
grown at us we think in the
entrepreneurial way
and i think that that's at the end what
makes entrepreneurship so exciting
because it's just problem solving really
that that's what it comes down to
yeah quinn and exhausting
and exhausting yeah quinn
safety flare and we have to start if
you're comfortable of course
with a personal experience because that
it makes sense that a company like flair
would be triggered from something like
that
yeah so flair was born out of my own
personal experience with assault and my
co-founders experience but what we soon
realized was that
safety is much bigger than sexual
assault
it doesn't have a gender it doesn't have
an age
it affects literally everybody
and for the longest time it has been run
by these people who
quite frankly don't experience the
situations as much as we do
and so they've been talking about
the stereotypes of what you think about
safety right
you're walking down a dark alley and
somebody grabs you and it's a stranger a
stranger danger
but the reality is is that
more than 70 of assaults happen with
some of the you know
in a familiar place and safety isn't
just about
assaults it's about your health it's
about getting
access to people when you need help it's
about not feeling alone
when you're alone knowing that you have
a community and a safety net and a
network of people who care about you
who will call you who will come to your
location
or who will call the authorities an
emergency response on your behalf
and so my co-founder and i developed
a technology platform it's made up
of a mobile app and
first safety jewelry so they look like
this for everybody who's watching via
video
uh for those who aren't you can go to
get flare g-e-t-f-l-a-r-e dot com
yep promo and
it's a really discreet bracelet it
actually looks like jewelry not like
technology
but yeah but there's a little you can
barely see it there's a little
technology module right in here with a
button
underneath in between your wrist and the
jewelry and
there's a button there where you can
activate a bunch of different features
because safe delay is deeply personal
you know michael if you and i were in
the same situation
we would have different reactions and
different things that we would want to
have happen at different times
so our focus is on providing people with
options
so that they can decide what's right for
them in the moment
so you can alert your friends send them
your location via text message ask them
to check in on you
if you're at a bar with your friend
which hopefully we will all be
in in a few months from now you can send
them a signal so that they know to come
and interrupt a conversation if you're
not feeling comfortable and you feel
trapped
not sure how to get out of it you can
also get a phone call
an incoming phone call and there's a
voice on the other end
there's actually 10 different options
actually more than 10
options that you can choose to it's a
recording and it sounds like your
roommate saying hey you really need to
come home
or your co-workers saying where are you
you're missing this meeting it gives you
an excuse that you need
in case you don't want to involve
anybody else and have to explain
why you felt like you needed an out or
you can
send a message to emergency response
with your active location
all from the press of a button and
nobody has to know that you pushed it
it's 2021. we have almost autonomous
vehicles we're going to mars
we are you know growing meat in a lab
how is this not a thing like it makes
perfect sense to me
it makes obvious sense that we that you
know it's the the basis
of you know if you're talking about
maslow's primitive needs you know
safety feeling safe and secure it's like
the number
one of the top things that we need just
after food and
the air perhaps why are not as many
people working on this why is it 20 21
and only now i finally meet a startup
that is that is working on on these
smart wearable devices that can provide
us with this
sense of safety yeah
frankly it's about damn time there are
millions of people that are affected by
their safety
every single day it's not an emergency
one-off
it's right how do i like where am i
going how am i getting there what am i
wearing
who do i know that's going to be there
how do i reach out to people will i have
service
it's all of these questions that we just
kind of
consider to be a part of our lives
because that's the reality that we're
operating in
but it doesn't have to be that way and
what really gets me
is that so many people hold back
from bringing their full selves to a
situation
from going to a work conference from
going to an event because
they're worried about what their safety
will be and they're worried about
somebody specific there who's made them
feel uncomfortable
maybe intentionally maybe not
intentionally and how to handle that
that shouldn't be the case like imagine
a world where
you didn't have to think about your
safety every day what could you do
how could you bring your full self to
those situations and what goals would
you accomplish
that's what i think the real value of
safety is
not just the avoidance of trauma and
avoidance of violence
even though those are very big parts of
it and
to be frank with you i don't know why
because we're not the first people
to well you know i'll be the first to
tell you that flair is not the only tool
to use for your safety it is a huge
problem that needs to be tackled from
so many different angles and
there are so many people there are
literally millions of people who have
been working on this issue because it
affects them so deeply
from a variety of different angles and
the fact that we haven't
made as much progress as we deserve is
astounding
it's why we partner with a lot of really
great organizations that tackle
laws a topical victim services that
tackle
cultural change and not shifting norms
but part of it has to do with
silencing people like people often ask
me like oh why are the numbers
so worse right now like why is it that
one in five
women in the us are assaulted or one in
four in college and one in three women
around the world experience violence in
their lifetime
those numbers aren't worse those numbers
are what they have been
um and we have a lot of data to back
that up
it's just that people are talking about
it more and
our culture has shifted so that we can
talk about it more
but frankly it hasn't been enough
because a lot of people have been
making companies that tell you this is
the one solution that you need to solve
all of your emergency situations because
that's how you experience safety when
that's not at all the case i view safety
and flare as a tool for your everyday
conversations your everyday
transportation your everyday
living your life so that you can feel
more
comfortable and more confident in those
situations
and know that it's okay to speak up if
somebody is being inappropriate
because you have a backup plan in case
that backfires on you
no that makes sense what what is the
hardest challenge that you're going
through
as you're building up as your building
flare is it you know the adoption
is it the technology what is you know
the thing that you're
more most you know concerning yourself
with as you go through this journey
yeah so that the answer to this question
changes all the time
sometimes it changes week to week day to
day month to month
um if we launched our company so we
spent about
four years developing the product
and that was user testing talking to
survivors about their own experience
really trying to understand where our
assumptions have been pushed and the
stereotypes existed around safety so
that we could break them down
and we knew that the industry had been
operating on stereotypes and assumptions
for a long time
and so we didn't want to do that
ourselves we didn't want to assume that
the situations we had were the
situations other people had
so we went out and talked to literally
thousands of people and did
iterative product development and
testing so that we could
improve as we went and get real-time
feedback and take that
seriously and actually make changes
based off of that
um and so we launched about a year ago
right into covet a fantastic timing i
give us an a plus for that
and at first it was you know
is this going to be a product that
people relate to anymore because they're
going to go
they're not going to be going out as
much or
are they going to be more comfortable
talking about their safety because now
they're hearing about it a lot
and part of your safety is your health
right
and so we
kind of like pulled back a little bit to
try to assess that
and and what we heard and what our
conviction was is that
safety is more important than ever the
typical tools that you use
to like try to solve this problem as
much as you can
don't exist there's no safety in numbers
on a subway when you're going to the
office if you're still going in like
healthcare workers were
or there's no safety on dates by going
to a familiar place or like having a
backup of a friend who could come
to your location i've definitely
selected date locations that i knew were
around the corner from my friend's place
if i needed it
um and there was a huge feeling of being
alone
and how do you stay safe when you're
alone when you can't call on the buddy
system for example
um and so frankly our biggest problem
right now
is is keeping up with folks who
um are really impacted by safety we are
um sold out completely and
we're still selling despite being on
pre-order
and so for us it's about how do we get
safety to more people
like we've made this tool that we know
can be helpful
and helpful for a wide range of
situations
whether or not you're um in an iffy
weird gray area with somebody and you
get a feeling in the pit of your stomach
and the hair on the back of your neck
sticks up
and you're not really sure what's
happening but you really shouldn't stick
around to find out
or whether you like having a health
concern and you really need an
ambulance to come right away there's a
lot of people with these different
needs and we are struggling to
get our tool out there as much as we can
because
as a mission-driven company as a
survivor founded company our goal is to
get everybody the safety options they
need
right i i think that what you're doing
is is inspiring
and you know the journey itself is
fascinating and
and i think that that's exactly what you
know what what inspires me through this
show is meeting these amazing
entrepreneurs that
you know that either they bring their
own personal experiences or are
understanding that you know something in
the world needs to change and i'm not
surprised that
you know also with your time in the
white house and harvard business school
and then
now i'm just excited about the the
positive impact you're making so
so thank you for that quentin for the
inspiration and before we leave i have
to ask the most important question
which is three words you would describe
yourself with
yeah i
really struggle with this question as i
think a lot of people do
because it's really hard to define
yourself by just one thing
you know at flare we believe that you
can be style
like beautiful jewelry and function
something that helps you
um and so even boiling it down
to three things is really hard
um so obviously i think the first one
is the word survivor and that one i
really struggle with
sharing as one of the three because it
wasn't a choice that i made
it was somebody else forcing a change on
my identity
in a single moment that i had no control
over
and to be frank with you i rejected it
at first
like many other people i refuse to admit
that i was assaulted
until like two years later and maybe it
was a year and a half
um and so that one is something that i'm
personally working on trying to
reclaim and that's part of my mission
with flair is to claim that word for
myself
and make it actively a part of who i am
rather than it being forced on me
the other thing that i would say is that
i am a advocate
and what i mean by that is i believe
that your job can be
something that you care about and that
can make a
positive impact on the world and frankly
i recognize
the privilege that i have in being able
to say that
because there's a lot of people who
don't have that same privilege that i do
and my last word is that it's privileged
i think that i'm very fortunate to have
a lot of people who are willing to trust
me with their own
stories of safety and they feel like
that can be used to create
good with and i try to remind myself of
that
every day gwen thank you
very very much for your time for your
openness
and for and most importantly for the
work that you're doing i i gained a lot
of inspiration and i can't wait to share
this with the world
and just thank you very much and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you it was uh so fun to talk to
you
thank you